[Music]
and hi hacker news submitted by love
from the 6th aka Toronto a 6 don't owe
the FBI is struggling to employ hackers
because they are all smoking weed also
they want a job though they can't go to
the drugs pass the drug test
get rid of the stupid weak drug test is
that oh these guys could protect our
country from [ __ ] foreign online
invaders but because they like to get
stone we're just gonna risk our country
are you become a hacker I want to know I
want to see like the beginning stages of
a hacker really call it computer science
[ __ ] whack a free call crackers yeah
so what they're referring is that the
Department of Justice found a 40% of FBI
cyber security positions or unfilled 70%
point all 40 percent like you know you
heard 70 and it said yeah sorry I'm
still one of the 134 computer scientists
that they were authorized like that they
were interviewing they didn't hire 52 of
them five of the 56 field offices didn't
get computer sciences assigned to them
because of this like the secretary can't
pass the final drug test like these
people are actually showing up to the
interview hi
don't you tell me crazy oh I guess now
then no I guess we shouldn't have them
at FBI agents because we don't really
want stoners to work as a investigators
or not agents right there just hackers
not there FBI hiring well yeah but it's
for the cybersecurity 30 they probably
pretty big scope of responsibility it's
a pretty big because a bit like project
to project I'm viewing it like swordfish
you know how Hugh Jackman they bring
them in they give them a test hat this
website while this girl gives you a blow
job
yeah watch it get a shock Hugh Jackman
on screen swordfish yeah
too bad you got a die no no wait I don't
remember that [ __ ] okay that was that
was the famous when she first showed and
found some kid I know that's the only
thing I remember all I remember is I'll
be there and her gold me will I remember
to dig so I thought wow that's intense I
was like that I don't know how you can I
don't know what to focus on I mean
coordination I'm [ __ ] mixing up all
these yeah that's why I'm saying so if
it's like that then I think like a
little bit of weed is okay it's project
for project you hire these guys for this
project boom swordfish is done get out
here I think they're trying to hire them
like full-time staff Oh a lot of
positions that need to be filled like a
lot I wish I would celebrate I'll be
like you guys would never work for the
FBI if anybody shows up with a Rasta hat
you know they're wearing a [ __ ]
poncho they're smoked out and then they
come on to my job interview and I'm like
what the [ __ ] you guys would always not
want to be a part of FBI now you guys
want to come in let's work we [ __ ] with
your short-term memory right I don't
know if they're smart enough to hack and
be good at it they could smoke all the
way that they want but yeah I mean when
when it's a federal federal offense
so how can you just have you seen how
well people freestyle on weed all man
it's amazing I don't know I just way out
what's the what's the bigger evil here
North Korean hackers wait they got she
the internet Russian hackers with offer
that could mess with our campaigns and
politics or a pot-smoking guy that needs
a job I just don't know what a hacker
does per se like you know because we
always talk when you see the movies like
I'm a happen I'm like what do you do
what's the program that you open like
when you hack something and you get onto
a computer because I know it's not that
easy because it's whatever the movies
they go to a computer the puppet of a
computer screen and there's just [ __ ] on
there it doesn't work like that so how
the [ __ ] that means
yeah how does it really work that's the
only thing I know like I just told ago
okay we have come here done and also the
door open
so that what we're
so how does that lead to like catching
balls in there I don't know how that's a
Matt not the ultimate hacker
you mean the matrix yes you got to go
inside the [ __ ] computer but you also
get a needle in your brain
another problem as to why they can't
fill these positions is because they
find that a lot of startups would pay a
lot more for these computer scientists
rather than actual government so then a
lot of computer scientists are like well
if I can get more money over here why am
I going to work over here
even more reason because they could stay
smoking weed exactly then yeah it's like
they don't care about the patriotic duty
or protecting this country they just go
Angry Birds hey mol money and I can keep
smoking weed party like a rock star
the FBI need to change their policies
yeah and you quit being a little [ __ ]
tight asses and Hall monitors need to
change their [ __ ] because if they got
some agents that will go undercover and
do climb and [ __ ] like that
do hackers get guns on this one you have
to be like a field agent or special as
you get done I don't know I just your
age and I assume between asleep in a gun
another thing that they're pointing out
is the lack of diversity so why cuz FBI
is only black people no no not not in
race in gender only 11% other staff is
women which is way lower than the matura
percentage of women in the IT because
girls hate computers no all of them oh
girl yeah the Heil
I really given a girl a good laptop on
her birthday you can't even keep that no
absolutely [ __ ] she gets [ __ ] pissed
if Casey proposed to you with the
[ __ ] like I'm a modern terrific if we
plug a pit but no we can't stay that far
it's Texas we can't we can't say there's
there's no girls better how you can't
say it like that there's no girls that
are hackers you know our girls are
hackers but they just hate computers
it's weird because when they have like
this fallout it when I what I hear when
you hear that statistic right it's like
they're well I guess even closer they're
sexist or something but all I'm thinking
is that it's because those are positives
would be more interesting than the
[ __ ] computer science that's all I
think about
that's what you think they're not hiring
because they're women or do you think
they're not hiring because girls just
not into that [ __ ]
a lot of women aren't being hired
because they would rather work for a
startup company because there's a less
wage gap so the government's [ __ ] up
all these kinds of businesses are better
and pay I'll get paid more than women
yeah which is like in a lot of I think
you hear more about the glass ceiling
and like federal jobs government just
keep sucking up so they go oh we can't
fire hacker and you can't hurt well
that's your fossil could start out that
they're paying better they let you smoke
weed they let grow then of course you're
going to get the bit less girls and
that's not the issue I think it should
be saying they're the girls rather not
work why would I go work for the FBI if
I could work for this other company yep
get paid more smoke weed and I probably
get the best the best equipment and I
have to drive a [ __ ] boring ass Crown
Victoria would you like men in black
which is kind of cool come crown vics
I'm pretty okay so I think I looked into
homes from Milan you can buy a carpet
boy I'll think about it because my
Porsche lease is almost up and I was
looking for you believe course but I
want to get black and white one with the
lights and stuff but then I thought no
well pretty smart I've got a website
because they're all supercharged and I
found a website but the problem is you
need to be a police officer in order to
go even go to I would just want the
black and white just so that people can
like get away from him I can't be funny
but yeah that's not gonna be completely
different reason I think it's a great
idea what's it was a great idea pitiful
it'll be time to say hey big write-up
let's let people smoke weed on the job
as FBI agents case closed
I can't just go tabby cat yeah their
same in order to be hired FBI you have
to be clean for three years let me ask
you this one years three years yes to be
drug so why is the government
complaining right now [ __ ]
complaining ass [ __ ] they're like
well we can't find anything good yes
your rule it made them the reason why
you're losing and you're all these
startups are getting all the hackers is
because you guys are tight Adams yeah I
don't want to work for you there's less
girls there and if you're a girl you get
paid like [ __ ] and then there's [ __ ]
nothing to do but boring [ __ ]
and you can't even smoke a little bit a
weed for three years why why would you
even want to get in there that's a
[ __ ]
I rather [ __ ] work for a company that
makes video games when you tap that
[ __ ] and a [ __ ] bird jumps up
and down that's way better and you can
smoke all the weed you want and have fun
well yeah screw our national security
professional security duping yeah they
should make it better they should make
it fun come to the Sabha where you could
[ __ ] lurk into people's computers
don't you want to see what Trump is
doing right now let's take a look guys
hey come over here we have a whole
[ __ ] grow up you could smoke a little
bit of weed it's like Google get better
all the [ __ ] evidence [ __ ] that they
have got from all the criminals they
[ __ ] use it in the playroom so you
come to the FBI come over here
hey you guys want a little better heroin
on your break okay let's have a little
bit hello eight you know where we
confiscated these guns and we have a gun
range go ahead and use our blowtorch it
don't matter it's all good
that's what that's how you attract the
hackers they'll be like [ __ ] that I
working for this [ __ ] app company I
will come to the pho by and I'm gonna
catch some criminals it's good Red Hawk
with Joe that's how you [ __ ] run a
country [ __ ] will stop mutter people I
hope you guys enjoyed this video and if
it's your first time here welcome please
subscribe we're going to give you more
videos like this one
[Music]